for 13 years they gathered at the gates
of timbuktu for three days in january
thousands of nomads celebrated the
festival oldaser with guests from home
and abroad
normally the kel tamashek lived
scattered across the sahara region
they got together once a year the
festival was something of a family
reunion
in 2013 woodstock in timbuktu was
released
it is a film by german director desiree
fontrota
mani anza is the director of the desert
festival
when we started the festival mali was
just coming out of a civil war a
rebellion that destroyed a lot
especially between nomads and settled
people
some 10 000 people celebrate together in
the desert
daytime is for traditional music and
dance
evenings the stage is reserved for
malian rock bands
2013 saw the last of the timbuktu
festivals at least for now
the city was occupied by islamic
extremists
musicians and festival organisers
received death threats and fled to
neighbouring countries
manny ansar also went into exile in
berlin he and desiree fontrota met again
mali is no longer a safe place for
musicians
it's like this
that music
everything that has music and not
chapters of the quran that are sung
is the work of the devil according to
salifi political islam
is islam
that totally contradicts the traditions
of the region
festival organizers managed to take
individual musicians out of refugee
camps
now they're touring the world as the
caravan of peace
the caravan is our answer to the bearded
ones
and music hara abi also had to flee
extremists destroyed her studio and
tortured her musicians
the festival in exile
like here in berlin
it gives us courage
until the end of time
foreign
berlin's false burner theatre is packed
even so the biggest dream of the caravan
and its musicians remains to celebrate
again in the desert in 2015
you